what their parents said or just because
of what a community says or what society
says in general what you can and cannot
do with your life what you have to be
doing at the age of 25 at the age of 27
at the age of 30.
i have a quote here i think from you i
decided to take it into my own hands and
write the dream role i always wanted to
play
so
i've been in hollywood for a while and
i've auditioned for a lot of roles and a
lot of the roles that i was auditioning
for
tended to be
the the same type of role so
they were very
they were stereotypes they were putting
me in a box of these characters
would be going through an arranged
marriage or they would have strict
parents or
they would be
pursuing a career that they didn't
necessarily want to pursue but they were
too afraid to do the other thing
and
so i just noticed you know like a couple
of those roles i'm like oh okay this
feels interesting this feels like a new
way of telling the story but then it
just kept happening that it was the same
role over and over
and
and i just i didn't really understand it
but then but then i understood that
hollywood sees
different ethnic groups as monoliths and
only sees this person in this type of
role as as a doctor or or a smart uh
tech person
and
so for me
i
just wanted to be able to
play a role where where it was more
nuanced and maybe there are bits and
pieces of that as as in in definition
please monica does have a science
background which is somewhat of a
stereotype but i wanted to take that
that that genius stereotype and that
science background and
merge it into something new and that i
hadn't seen before and and and i said
okay well you know she smokes weed and
she hooks up with guys and and she's
pretty chill
except in this one family department and
so it was exciting for me to play
and create a role
that had so many facets to it
instead of this one thing
and and that's what i set out to do
in terms of casting
the roles in my film
a really fun story for me was when i
uh got a hold of anacosa who plays jaya
the mom in my film and
she said yeah of course send me the
script and then i sent her the script
and
she responded by saying
i've played a lot of south asian moms
she has played
priyanka's mom in quantico she has
played jamilah's mom on the good place
she has played ritesh who is
plays the role of sunny in my film she
played his mom on his tv show stitchers
already
so she had already played his mom before
and she said i've never seen
this role before and this is really
exciting because the mom in my movie has
such a fun arc and she said that it was
just going to be really fun to play
that role because she had never been
offered something like that before and
and that was exciting for me to hear
because i wanted to not only write
the role for myself that i wanted to
play but i wanted to write other
characters that my friends who had maybe
been offered certain types of roles in
the past that they would also be excited
to come in and be like oh i've never
gotten to do this before thank you for
giving me this opportunity
and your brother has an arc too
yes yes
yes all the characters i i definitely
wanted to make sure that
every single character has has their own
story in their own journey
how do you feel about actors who
refuse to write roles for themselves
create their own work so they don't want
to be put in a box they don't want to
have to play the same
type of person over and over again but
then they're not willing to
create work that they actually want to
watch
i feel that
a lot of people are different and and
some people just don't have uh
like the patience or the discipline to
sit down on a computer and write their
own roles but then i say
you gotta go out and make writer friends
you gotta make these writer friends you
gotta make these filmmaker friends these
are director friends and and get them
excited about your story get them
excited about the roles that you want to
play and that you haven't seen so if you
feel like you can't do it yourself then
surround yourself with other creative
people who maybe can do that for you
and in this day and age do you think
it's reasonable for people not to want
to create their own work because it's
it's not
about sitting home waiting for someone
to call anymore so much of work is
self-generated
today i think in this day and age you
really do have to go out and create your
own work and there's no excuses anymore
like i said the iphone 13 just came out
and
if you've looked at the cinematic mode
of that iphone
you can make an amazing short film
shot on the iphone 13 and get
sound equipment from amazon and
just have it have really great cinematic
quality and have really great sound and
you don't even have to go that far
there are tick tock videos that i watch
of
different people and their parents and
their grandparents that are
just as exciting and even if you don't
feel like you can go as far as to make a
short film you can make little videos on
tick tock or youtube or
instagram live
and
figure out what works for you and maybe
put videos up on snapchat and if that
doesn't work for you then
take another path like i said it's all
about taking risks it's all about
actually doing it so even if you think
oh i can't write this for myself
then
make a friend go to these ucb sketch
writing classes go to these improv
classes you'll make friends in those
classes that's what i've done and then
you continue to work with those people
that you really gel with and that's
what's exciting so find your community
and
all create work together
do you wish you had started writing
earlier in your career
i started writing pretty young so i
started writing short stories and poems
and songs since
i don't know second grade or something i
was always
really into my books i was always really
into stories when i would go to
the indian parties with my parents on
the weekends graduations birthdays and
anniversaries and thanksgivings i was
always sitting in the corner reading my
book just into my stories and that
inspired me to write my own stories and
so i've i've
written stories that i've transferred
into scripts and
so i
started writing very young and i was
always really good like i mentioned i
was really good at math and science but
i was also good at english too so
that was part of it and i enjoyed
writing it gave me a break from the from
the rigid structure of math and science
and and it was always a stress reliever
for me
so i
i really enjoyed writing from a very
young age so transferring it over to
screenwriting wasn't a hard thing to do
for me
so when you would be going to those
parties and family barbecues whatever
and you had the book where people like
put the book down come join us what are
you doing never never that that's not an
indian thing to do
okay like oh she's studying
reading like babysitter's club or sweet
valley twins or sweet valley high i
wouldn't necessarily be studying but
but in the indian american community you
don't really stop a kid from reading
okay ever do you feel you have a choice
to write direct and act or it's a
compulsion
like you can't not do it
it's a compulsion
and i think it goes back to your first
question of having a backup plan
and
there's honestly i think there have been
various acting classes that i've been in
out here and they always say if there's
anything else that you want to be doing
you need to go out and do that instead
of
being in entertainment
there's honestly nothing else i would
rather be doing and i know that if i had
stayed at that job at accenture i would
be making billions and millions of
dollars at this point and
been promoted and
that just wasn't it for me and it
it's not about the money and it's about
waking up every day and getting to live
my dream and that's
what keeps me going and
that's where the compulsion comes from
do you ever have friends that took that
path and there's nothing wrong with that
path who say why i secretly envy you i
love that you went out on your own
and you kind of forged your way and you
didn't
worry about
whether you had this title or that at
this point
all the time
lots of friends who went a certain path
that they were
maybe supposedly had to go down because
of
what their parents said or just because
of what a community says or what society
says in general what you can and cannot
do with your life what you have to be
doing at the age of 25 at the age of 27
at the age of 30. and
uh
yeah there are a lot of friends that are
envious of
what i'm doing and
um i'm just really happy to be living
the life that i'm living
how many characters have you actually
created for yourself
multiple i've created so many characters
for myself and some of those characters
have probably never made it to the
screen but they're still on the page or
they're still in my mind and
and it's exciting because none of them
are the same and they're all based on
maybe something small
something real that has happened to me
an experience or a thought or an
inspiration
um
but but all those characters are so
different and that's what's exciting
because there are so many roles that
i've created for myself that i'm excited
to play very soon
and to
imagine
them visually on screen
is is what i live for
what's one that you haven't created yet
that
you want to play like it would really
take you out of your comfort zone or
challenge you
i feel like my role in definition please
was pretty challenging that's one of the
most dramatic pieces that i've ever
written it's definitely a
dramedy but but it it leans into that
drama
for bits of the script and i think going
to those vulnerable places as an actor
i was just really lucky to
surround myself with amazing actors that
truly brought it and and made me a
better actor and so
playing the role of monica in definition
please was very challenging and very
fulfilling on its own and
and and i believe that there are roles
percolating
in my head that that i'm not aware of
that that will come out at some point
and i'm excited to
face the challenge of those roles too
and i know you get asked this a lot but
how much of sujata was in that role
not a lot not a lot i think uh like i
mentioned the the entire script was
based on
me winning the my class spelling bee so
i obviously never won the national
spelling bee or else it would be
googlable
but
uh
that definition please and that
character was based on a lot of
different experiences and people that
i've come across
in
my life um
being around a really large flourishing
indian american community in western
pennsylvania and then also college and
after college i i took little pieces of
of my life to create the fictional world
of definition please
and so instead of a coming home story
it's a leaving home story because the
character has options she just chooses
her surroundings
yes okay and i don't care maybe i'm i
don't know spoilers here but how come
not not a coming home story where you've
where you decided to come home to
um
the same situation
but you you had the career what was the
difference why did you why did you do
the opposite
i think
what was really exciting for me to
explore with monica is the idea of a
stunted
growth the idea of
i've been successful i've had
the peak of my life what is ever going
to be better than winning
the national spelling bee
and those thoughts in your head oh
nothing's ever going to top that it's
like being the quarterback of the
winning team senior year of high school
and then 20 years later you are
not really doing much and so that that
kind of story is exciting to me of like
a stunted growth of
of how is this
how is my life like and how can i get
out of it as opposed to a coming home
story i feel like i've seen that many
times before and and i wanted to explore
something new in terms of uh in terms of
what you said a leaving home story
so reliving the glory of these different
because some people high school was not
their glory time
yes and and that was actually an awful
time and they don't want to relive it
but then there's others that they do
you're right they peak at a certain age
and i do i would imagine that would be
very difficult
and and and then
they don't nothing sort of the magic
never happens again yes yes i think
that's that's what's exciting to me that
that story